people of the internet retro reconciler
here and welcome back to harry potter
and the chamber of secrets this is our
let's play series and if it's your first
time here you should know
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories
they tell we post videos every week here
on
youtube including lots of content about
hogwarts legacy and then also
uh harry potter let's plays animal
crossing videos all sorts of things so
here today we are almost completely out
of berdy berdybop beans because
we just bought alohomora so kind of
wrapping up from last time
these are the things we took care of
we're getting ready to end that day
and go into what i believe is
technically day three
so we got the copy of hogwarts history
we showed it to hermione and now we are
ready to move forward
all right let's see where gryffindor
stands today
oh no what no we didn't get any points
that day
that was terrible hufflepuff now only
down
one slytherin was already ahead of us
now they're just down
one let's see how much
oh no wait
wait what slytherin loses two points
and now we have a very close race
between gryffindor ravenclaw hufflepuff
and slytherin for a second i was like
wait it can go
down and then i remembered yes the the
teachers of course they can take away
points
as well so let's see what the next day
at hogwarts will bring i'm pretty pumped
that we do have the uh
morning alahomora spellman
transfiguration first thing
isn't it oh nice yeah first floor i'll
meet you there
first floor got it ron got it okay so
what can we get into along the way can
we talk to neville here neville what's
up
the snakes must be quite cool i bet they
don't have much to say
do they you'd be surprised neville
you could be surprised
let's see what's on the board here we're
missing items we still need to find that
potions kit bag okay so we already found
or no we we found the potions get bag
right so now we need to find the
gryffindor merit badge
dropped while wandering around the grand
staircase i mean
that's a little broad that's a little
broad
but you know what we can make an effort
to find it hello
oh wait what are you saying all the air
of slytherin is it true
and did you really order that snake to
attack your classmates
none of it come on man and i didn't
order the snake to attack my classmates
exactly leave them alone i'll believe
you harry
though thousands wouldn't thousands
wait what i'll believe you though
thousands wouldn't
bro it like just happened how do you
already know thousands of people don't
believe me
so yeah the other good thing about
getting alohomora is now i can unlock
any of those
dude this isn't anywhere close to the
grand staircase
but okay i'll take it that's the
gryffindor merit badge
very nice i might actually run back in
there right now and get the wizard card
for it for turning it in
but before we do that let's get a couple
birdie bop beans while we're ready
all right we're gonna go straight back
to that bulletin board i hope it go
we'll go ahead and give me another one
as well yes it did nice
so the next one is the telescope dropped
walking from astronomy tower somewhere
around the grand staircase
if found please return to this notice
board so another one that says
it's near the grand staircase but you
guys saw how that one really
wasn't all that near the grand staircase
knows 56
miranda goshawk hey miranda goshawk
famous spellbook writer very nice wait
which one did she write again
let me know in the comments if you
remember don't look it up don't look it
up
okay if you want you can look it up but
first try and see if you can post it
without looking it up
miranda goshak famous spellbook writer
i'm pretty sure that she wrote the
standard book of spells that's my guess
standard book of spells
all right so now we're on the lookout
for any chests with
alohomora but also
uh that telescope now i really don't
like
the the camera in this is just terrible
i mean see look at that
the only way i was able to to get a get
a read on him is by locking on
what's over here is it still locked can
i use aloha more
on that i'm pretty sure you can't but
let's switch to that right there
oh wait we gotta like do a big alamoura
nope still didn't work
okay let's knock this guy over let's go
this way
all right before we do anything i'm
gonna try and lock on to these guys
because i know they're lurking about i
know they're still in here
now the reason i'm going back through
this way is because i want to see
i've unlocked quite a few spells now and
i want to make sure that there's not
anything
uh like special that i can open up any
chests or anything like that
i know there were some in classrooms
that had like the
scourge or require the scourge bell
and i think there might have been one or
two
that required aloha as well
okay they'd already pushed this pretty
sure we did but
oh yeah it just opens that up okay nice
all right all right that's cool
you know what i'm gonna stop spending so
much time on the birdie bop beans
because
when you're really doing the missions
you unlock
quite a few anyway
oh this is the spot where i got stuck
last time
remember that that that he just kind of
trapped us
okay there's a chest down there already
been opened so i think we're good on
that one let's go out right here
where am i supposed to be meeting ron
again i already forgot
let's look this i mean this is why they
give us the remember all right
transfiguration class first floor okay
got it got it now the question is do i
want to go this way
okay i already opened that all right
anything over there nope oh wait what is
this
i knew he was gonna get me man they
don't stay
stunned long enough like i feel like it
wears off really quickly
where are you supposed to go up here is
this just a dead end that's interesting
yeah we're about to get absolutely
annihilated we don't get out of here
let's get it just just get out of here
harry just leave i feel like that little
area up at the top though has got to be
for something else
all right we already did that one
see is that okay we could open that or
we could open this
okay this just leads right back out here
okay so where does the other one lead it
begs the question right
where does the other door lead
oh i'm pretty sure we've already been in
here too oh but this is the yeah
oh i don't have incendio yet man
[Music]
i don't think so do i let me double
check
no so we're just missing two spells
right now one of them's
gotta be incendio because okay see we
gotta remember
you guys have to remind me commenters
don't let me beat this game if you
follow along with each video
do not let me beat this game without
coming back here
once i got incendio see that one right
there we've gotta
open that chest up and see that's really
why i'm doing this anyway
i wanna look for these and find ones
that have the little
uh green sludge
for lack of a better word i think they
actually said it was something to do
with the ghost
some sort of uh ghost residue that they
leave behind
wow these really have a lot of beans
i could totally be making that up but i
i pretty sure
in one of the missions it said something
about that being
from a ghost all right well that was
still worth it just for those bloody bop
beans in there i think
okay so now let's go back this way
and go right here okay are we on the
first floor this actually
this might be first floor oh incendio
challenge chambers will let me in there
yeah
yeah i didn't think so
all right i just said i was not i was
gonna stop doing this i was gonna stop
going for just the random
it's indio challenge chambers library
annex we don't want to go in there right
now
and girls bathroom so this one's gotta
be
oh yeah this is that one that just ends
like right there
okay so it's some of the other
classrooms that
second floor charms and library maybe
it's defense against the dark arts
there's one area where there's just a
bunch of classrooms
yeah this is it this is it
all right so we already opened that one
now let's get
to the main classroom area here
because i'm almost positive dude that up
near this right here there it is yes
okay that's aloha more you see the
little key on the front of it
let's go dude what's in there
what's in there yes wizard card
number 95 yardley plaque a
serial goblin killer yikes 1446-1557
yardley platt wow
he looks pretty mean right
kind of resembles malfoy a little bit
got that slicked back blonde hair there
all right well it was worth it for the
wizard card now if there may be another
one in here too
yeah there it is the scourge one perfect
okay so i need to i need to enable that
one
let's go right here
another wizard car maybe let's go
dude back to back wizard cards who we
got here
number 93 heathco barbary
yeah definite musician there heathcote
barbary 1974 to present
plays rhythm guitar with the popular
wizarding band the weird sisters
all right nicely done okay so we're
already
two out of ten on our way to more
uh unlocking more health so when you get
10 wizard cards in this
version of the game it actually gives
you more health
all right let's keep it moving keep it
moving so now we need to go i think we
got
make sure we're not missing any chests
here all right let's head back this way
all right well that was worth the trip
let's head down to transfiguration now
and meet up with ron maybe we're gonna
learn a new spell there
i hope so because then that would only
mean uh we would only have one spell
left
man it's crazy when i look back on this
game as a kid
i just felt like hogwarts was so big
and now playing it as an adult i'm just
like wow
it's it's such a super small area
it's really not that big
but i mean for the time they they did a
pretty good job with it
let's talk to you collect famous witches
and wizard cards
i'll give you card number two cornelius
agrippa oh number 59
gregory the smarmy i don't have that
card
oh no because you can get duplicates in
this
uh in this version let me see if we can
pull up our
uh it's in the folio magi here we go i'm
almost positive there's at least
one where you can tell i have a stack of
like two cards
it's gonna be the very last page just
watch just watch
it's totally gonna be the last page
like just just lock it in last page
i knew it dude i knew it dymph no
affirmation we have two of those so if
anybody asks for
dymphna firmage we can trade that one
without uh
worrying about losing it or anything all
right ron let's go to class dude let's
go in
all right is this it right here let's do
it man transfiguration i should have
known that you would be here today we
shall learn the transfiguration spell
known as avatar that's right i have a
photo aeropores will allow you to
transform
small objects such as the parts of this
statue
into birds this is achieved like so
of a fours very you can now see that a
crawl space has been revealed in the
wall
beyond this is the other forest
challenge
mr potter come forward please
yeah dude mr potter's ready yes
professor
the before spell book is located on the
other side of this crawl space
find it and the spell will be yours you
must then return here to the classroom
yes professor off you go
off you go harry all by yourself man
well that got creepy ominous music
like sending him to his doom geez the
cage rolls in front
they are not messing around at hogwarts
this year whoa
relax dude this looks like it'd be a
chamber of secrets area
okay already looks like a spot where we
need to use scourge down there
this guy is going to require
i think he requires expelliarmus so we
need to go ahead and put
that on and then what
else you guys think i should use we
already know we need scourge we'll just
keep these three for now
all right so wait where am i supposed to
oh probably not that way
i was trying to go
on that platform
oh goodness the ghosts come out here too
when you destroy it
i thought about it like at the last
second
oh look at that you like that dodge you
like that dodge right there oh oh
look out look out okay let's push this
all right we got one of the greats
opened up
relax i just want a couple of the birdy
bop beans
out of this vase and then we'll be on
our way man these ghosts are
messed up the ghosts were not this
hostile in the actual harry potter
series
oh there we go nice job harry
unfortunately i'm not gonna go that way
anyway yet
yep we're ready this time
all right you got another button to
press here and
see this right here almost looks like a
little button that you're supposed to
stand on to
activate another switch all right both
of those are open
and unlocked now ready to go relax
i have no idea if i have a wigan weld
potion either i'll check after this
let's see do we have one uh
fill with stamina ooh so i guess that i
i guess that means it's empty
yikes we should have went and done that
before we
started this like that little quick
dodge though right
you like that little quick dodge there
oh there's a flapindo
spot see that on the wall up there the
little hand
now i feel like this guy at some point
is going to attack
okay wait so which where am i supposed
to go
is it straight ahead here we go come on
it's not that far of a fall
it's really not that far should be okay
harry
all right yeah we
definitely needed that actually
replenish a little bit of health
[Music]
you know maybe we'll get lucky and
though there will be a wiggin weld
replenish area down here oh my goodness
three
ghosts hiding in here maybe i should use
lumos
of course you guys just want me to keep
switching spells
so i like that they have it where you
can use any spell and i like the fact
that they
want you to use multiple spells but what
i dislike is that
i feel like three is really
i wish there was a way that it could be
more than three
all right anywhere else
oh i almost missed that and it's a
wizard card let's go
dude let's go
already three five blenheim stalk
blenheim
stalk 1920 to present another one who's
alive at the time of harry potter
expert on the non-magical and author of
many books including
people who notice a study of awareness
of magic
in the non-magical that sounds
interesting actually
sounds pretty interesting like muggles
who are still able to somehow
detect the magic and notice it they're
not as easily
deceived by maybe some of the veils and
things that
dumbledore uses not just dumbledore
anybody in hogwarts
any wizard i guess okay wait what am i
missing here is that
all there is back here
oh we need to get up top don't we
yeah look at that there's more stuff all
up there
okay so i guess let me yeah those are
the ones we already did i guess we just
go back through
i'm a little confused i feel like we
missed something obvious in there
okay that's blocked off we can't go
there
so yeah we definitely need to get
did not see that before wait did it just
close back
it did interesting
okay so we need something heavy then
apparently to hold that down
like can i not fight this guy
i feel like this guy might be the key
of course we also know we need to cast
flupindo on that
can he make that jump
let's go harry nice job dude
i don't know if that's gonna help me
though oh
okay wait a minute though we can't i
think those little egg looking things
with the eyes
i'm almost positive we have to have a
force for that
so yeah we're missing something i feel
like we're missing something
obvious here and we're gonna lose health
for that that was my fault i forgot
maybe i do i need to like stand on it
for a
okay it opens the door behind me
let's go back this way we missed
something
we missed something guys
okay so we definitely can't go that way
there is we could use lumos in more
places to see if it reveals
a hidden path somewhere
okay so we did all this we go in here
that's where the ghosts come out and it
actually gives you a prompt
and says to use lumos and that opens up
over here
which then oh
wait why did it hold on hold on
i guess it's just like hey pay attention
here
this is where you can climb up that was
sneaky man we we just completely missed
that first
time all right now where can we
jump off
um anywhere
definitely oh right there
jump hurry invincibility frames
i'll take it oh no
like what do you do there man what do
you do there
i don't know of anything honestly
wall sneak they're just gonna be flying
all over here
probably attacking me
no okay all right they moved on
i had to open my big mouth i just had to
open my big mouth
completely jinxed it man okay i'm gonna
wait for you to pass
the camera dude it's so bad
makes this way more difficult than it
should be let's go for the invis frames
yes invincibility frames
for the win oh clearly you do not get
invincibility
right there we're losing so many beans
too
i wish they would just give you a spell
like to combat them
maybe i should try scourge on them since
that what is what makes them
are you serious right now
oh that is painful
that is painful dude like i
i did the exact same thing that i've
done the whole the whole way
around and that time his jump it's just
like
not enough for whatever reason all right
let's see if we can actually fight these
guys
[Music]
nope can't do anything so it's just like
sorry
you're gonna take a hit right here
that's pretty frustrating i mean we
might die now
it's reading pretty low on health if one
of them just decides
to attack us while we're sliding along
this
tiny little ledge here
i cannot believe that man i was worried
about it before
and then it was like so forgiving on the
way over there that i'm like oh okay
we're good
and then in the last spot it was like he
just didn't have enough
just didn't have enough range on that
one man
[Music]
it's so annoying down to 40 vertibop
beans
40 bertie bought every flavor beans
are you serious right now
we lost five beans this is unfair
completely unfair
there we go
i knew it man i knew it i was just at a
bad angle
all right get through here quickly
please we need a chest and we need some
like chocolate frogs
hey what what am i supposed to do here
okay wait a second
i guess we just drop and walk around
yeah there you go harry
watch here they come
too close man yeah we we better have
invis frames in the cutscene
[Music]
or in i guess it'd be invince invince
frames
all right here we go chapter seven
figuring out transfiguration transforms
small objects into birds
transfiguration is some of the most
difficult magic to practice effectively
it is extremely difficult
for example to transform something
non-living
into something that is alive however
mastering a transfiguration spell such
as abafors
which will transform small inanimate
objects into birds
can be both rewarding and useful
all right and that one was for alohomora
all right so let's go ahead and put this
on
b right now we haven't really used
flupindo all that much
all right now we've
oh that's handy
that's handy unfortunately we are almost
out of
health
please we need a chest with like some
pumpkin pastries
i know they're pumpkin pasties but for
whatever reason the game's like no
pumpkin pastry
two pumpkin pasties please
okay let's get this one right here
that was too close man are you serious
it still actually hit me oh now i'm
definitely dead
oh man wait am i actually okay hold on i
keep the spell
and my health is refilled that's
actually not too bad it kept me in the
exact same room i was in i'm okay with
that actually
i think that's more than fair more than
fair
what's not fair is how those ghosts
there's like no defense for them
all right where are you going
wait where are you going i hear you
flapping
okay this is interesting do i just i
guess i just crawl through
see i always i make it too complicated i
was like thinking i need to look through
and like cast a spell at a switch
through the
window or something no just crawl
through
just go ahead and crawl through harry
that's all it takes are these notes
right here oh that's pretty cool
transfiguration lessons and i wish you
could actually
wish you could actually read these easy
but
looks like it looks like a big warning
right there
something about without support warning
do not do this yeah
that's cool man that's cool i just wish
it was a little more uh
legible all right so now we're back in
here
of course the ghosts are just
immediately attracted to us
[Music]
all right now we can use abba fors
uh let's go ahead and go across yep
totally botched that
gonna take a hit right there
that's one thing that like you can just
tell with modern games has been so much
improved just like the detection of
walls and the detection of when you're
clearly trying to grab a ledge
things like that all right so let's try
this one over here first
there we go barely i almost messed it up
now watch that one's gonna go after me
not give me any time to dodge
i told you dude i told you
that's so ridiculous all right should i
go ahead and go to the other side
or is it just the same thing all right
since i'm already over here let's do
this one
i'm gonna need to put flopindo back on
too
uh and just to avoid i'm so used to
having flopindo on b
i'd just be weird if i if i don't keep
it there
this will move avaforce over to x for
now
look look at that like what do you do
man what do you do there's no way to
dodge when i'm on the ledge
like i feel like things like that like
that's poor game design
that's just poor game design there's no
defense for it like there's no
there's no way i can hide right there
um there's no way i can i can duck down
there's no spell as far as i know
there's no spell that i can cast it's
just like
tough luck there he is he's in your way
there's nothing you can do
or she i guess i should say
these all appear to be female ghosts
[Music]
alright so send him back over there
oh can i should i cast it hold on
watch me get all the way over here and
it not allow me to cast it
i probably should have cast it from over
where i was
again this would be poor game design too
if it doesn't let me oh my goodness it's
not gonna let me guys
it's not gonna let me i can't cast
anything
like come on he could move his wall he
could just like reach over
cast the spell
all right let's go over here i mean can
we even hit it from here yeah okay
i knew better i knew better than to like
try to walk over there and do it
and i don't even know that this is going
to matter like i guess it's going to
open up that other gate when i do this
and i said we would get plenty of birdie
bop beans in the challenge well
clearly i was misguided on that i was
very very wrong
because we have lost all our birdie bob
beans nearly all of them we've got two
remaining
which means a ghost should be coming by
any second to take those final two
these ghosts have just been relentless
back here there you go we're down to one
now
okay and we're almost down
our health again is just about to go out
oh now that dude's gonna attack watch
because yeah that's still closed look at
all those ghosts out there man
yeah i knew it i knew he was gonna come
after us now
now please don't tell me i have to deal
with the ghosts as well
the ghosts just need to get out of the
way
uh i'll keep that before's on since we
what was that dude
all right nice one hit
[Music]
the detection on this is so weird
like sometimes it hits the ground
there we go one more one more one more
we got this
there we go nice okay
oh one more avaforce
are you serious are you serious
the rail was in the way
all right what's he gonna do okay that
opens the front
where we can get out but what about like
oh does that just we've already been up
there yeah and this is just where the
statue is hanging out
so now we can just head back over here
oh no it's gonna make us crawl over
again isn't it
or like use the little uh yeah we have
to go
i have to go all the way back around
this way i think
right here
well guess what we don't have any more
birdie about beans for you to steal
ghosts no more birdy bop beans for you
to take for us
from us come on that's terrible game
design man
like i don't think there's any way
no matter how you time it
the only solution would be if there was
a spell to like get rid of them
at least temporarily all right let's see
if we got
if mcgonagall is pleased with our job
here
yeah back into the classroom harry nice
work
a superb job potter 40 house points
points for gryffindor 40 house points
for gryffindor
dismissed
important match against hufflepuff i
mean i kind of did but i'll meet you
outside the stadium i kind of did
if i'm being honest all right 250.
all right see what the remember all says
now quidditch match versus hufflepuff at
the quidditch stadium
okay before we do that though i do want
to kind of look around here
what is this can i like get back there
oh man what if you could like get back
in there
oh it's worth a try though right make
sure there's not any
special chests in here
how about birdie bob beans we need we
clearly need to replenish our birdie bop
beans now
oh we could go around and open up all
the student desks
come on did any of you leave like a
chocolate frog behind
there's one birdie bob bean that makes
the whole the whole thing worth it right
there
banana birdie bop bean all right what
else we got
come on we need some health dude
health please
they're not gonna give us any health are
they even if it's just one
i just don't want to be all the way down
like we are right now
because we're super super low
another birdie bot bean a gross one at
that
come on
watch it's gonna be come on last one
ah non-explodable luminous balloon darn
it
i thought for sure one of them would
have like a cauldron cake
all right you know what honestly what we
probably should do
is we oh there we go yes back to back
back to back
what we should probably do is go i think
when you're at the library
i believe there's a spot in there i'm
almost positive to refill your
wig can weld potion oh i can do this too
now
let's go ahead and uh switch back to
scourge
open it up another wizard card
dude so many wizard cards today just as
pilly wickle
so many wizard cards justice piliwickel
and would you look at that ladies and
gentlemen we have a wizard
who would be alive at the time of
hogwarts legacy
very few surprisingly so far very few of
these wizards that we've come across
in the wizard cards would be alive
during that late
1800s time frame that hogwarts legacy is
set to take
place yet here we have one finally
justice piliwickel
he is the celebrated head of the
department of magical
law enforcement so celebrated head you
would think that he's probably pretty
beloved then and looked upon
positively so who knows maybe he is a
character that we will
encounter at some point in the hogwarts
legacy video game
okay there's another one that's gonna
that one requires uh looks like
it's the spider webs it's gotta be
incendio
nothing here nothing here nothing here
all right let's go back up to the
library
i don't want to go to the entrance hall
just yet
transfiguration and i guess for the
library oh we can get to the library
here that's right that's right and
during the day it should be open no
problem we don't have to
like sneak around and yet it's making
the
sound like we like we are sneaking
around
oh we're not come on i'm just a student
going to the library
sheesh just relax guys see there's a
wizard in here and everything waiting
for me
all right we can weld potion
oh is it not in here it's got to be the
other way then come on
don't tell me i made this trip for
nothing yeah there it is
there it is hey how do i
oh what's wrong wait what
so i already have it filled i must
already have it filled
but it clearly says fill with
i guess the picture is i think the
purple inside
it's depicting that i do have it filled
but wait no because i died
in that other spot and it didn't but
maybe it was because i
fell in that big hole
interesting
that's that's actually pretty
interesting because i feel like
i don't know maybe maybe it doesn't work
when you fall in a hole like that maybe
it won't
it can't revive you from that
[Music]
yeah i don't think you have to pull uh
like equip it or anything i think it
should just
pop right up when i walk there but
definitely not now i already tried
diffendo
on all these um you know what let's just
just to make sure because it's been so
long it's like
it's quite a bit of time goes by between
my
my playthroughs of this where does this
lead
yeah i definitely did this already but
apparently i missed the chest
and it's a wizard card okay i didn't do
this
i thought for sure i came in there
another wizard
man purple the foul and that's a
duplicate right there
all right so hurple the foul we've got
two of him now we could trade him no
problem
now see at least with the books like i'm
just being reckless right now
if i cast a spell on the books
that will stop them at least for a time
yeah i really i really do need that
right there
i wish it would refill more health but i
really
really need that one
[Music]
that's so ridiculous i basically just
wiped out my gains from the
from the uh pumpkin pasty that i picked
up
all right so i mean might as well go
ahead and try definitely over here too
it's clearly i didn't remember something
and you know what let's go ahead and do
lumos as well just for good
measure just to make sure
that'd be like double hidden you know
they've got the big curtain up plus
you have to use lumos all right so we're
good there
now i also think there's a spot in here
where you can do the abafor
spell
yep right there okay so let's go all
three here
diffendo okay nothing
all right now let's do scourge
oh my goodness i always want to push
start to bring up this menu here
and let's just put it over actually put
it there and then put a before's there
all right i'm ready for the ghost
i'm ready for him it wasn't even there
fine
be that way then be that way ghosts
oh they're here though they're waiting
behind open it quickly
give me those invincibility frames
pumpkin pasty okay
[Music]
open this one open this one oh
the little owl treat that could come
into handy later
come on final chest in here and it's a
wizard card
dude all the wizard cards tonight
so many wizard cards and it's another
dupe of course
i think those are going to be needed for
like trading though
i shouldn't be doing this i shouldn't be
lingering
i should be getting through here as
quickly as i can
all right now this one is the one i'm
most looking forward to because i know
for sure
i haven't cast abaford's yet but
apparently i didn't do those either i
thought i had came up here in a previous
playthrough or not previous playthrough
but a previous
gameplay session but yeah man that's our
well our third wizard card just in this
little section number nine
gun hill drove gorsmall whoa dude
gun hilda of course gosmore
1556-1639 one-eyed
humpback witch famous for developing a
cure
for dragon pox that's pretty cool
so i'm sure she is uh thought of very
highly
dude just open the chest terry what
oh no
chocolate frog yeah chocolate frog
replenishes a lot more
[Music]
i should not be lingering guys i should
not be lingering
and it's all just for one bean there's
it's like completely such a waste of
time dude
doing all that for one bean when i'm
gonna lose more by getting hit
actually all right man you know what i
think that's to be a good spot for us to
end
guys if you enjoyed this video make sure
to give it a thumbs up next time we'll
be ready to start that quidditch match
with hufflepuff
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you guys again soon